okay can you guys hear me we're setting
up a little bit early but I figured that
it's it's about 9:30 and the coffee's
for the coffee is the coffee is finished
brewing I actually brewed I went ahead
brew three cups so we'll probably drink
a cup over the course of this livestream
and then I'll probably start getting to
work on a video about Ragnarok
I guess weighing the rock I think it's
how you pronounce it with the proper
Icelandic term oops where is that audio
coming from oh there it is oops well you
guys are gonna hear some feedback here
in a second but anyway yeah so I usually
keep the stream like I keep I keep it on
here so I can see what the picture looks
like what I'm talking in case there's
any kind of like disruptions or anything
but no you guys won't hear any feedback
because I have the desktop audio muted
there we go that's right we'll get it
together at some point anyway so so yeah
so I'll probably brew another cup
another couple of then have my other two
cups of coffee while I'm working on
Ragnarok I need my coffee this morning
Jesus it's like 9:30 in the morning I'm
going to pieces so I was reading this
stream and reading the chat before the
stream started and as we're waiting on
people to trickle and of course it
cracks me up some of the stuff you guys
talk about which by the way before we
get too far into this I have blacklisted
every term it has to do with age of
Ultron so anything relating the age of
Ultron will not appear in the chat just
FYI people in the in the film or people
in the chat a lot of them haven't seen
age of Ultron yet and I'm not one to
promote spoilers so the other thing that
I've done is I've been going through my
channel in the comments section and
anybody who tries to spoil age of Ultron
I just immediately leave their comment
and ban them from my channel because
I've told people ahead of time I put
on Twitter that anybody who tries to
spoil age of Ultron like intentionally I
mean it's it's obvious if it's
unintentional you know like where'd you
guys think about Quicksilver or
something like that and it's obviously
not an intentional spoiler but if
somebody says hey this happened in the
age of Ultron and it's clearly a spoiler
they'll just get banned no questions
asked I post that up on Twitter so
people know what in heck's going on
Vidia so anyway I was going through the
chat and it was it was funny to me
because people were asking the question
like who could win would Squirrel Girl
beat Superman and the answer is of
course like scrubber would destroy
Superman
like no questions asked it would be I
mean oh so many semi-firm requests maybe
no contests like squirrels defeated
every like I think she just recently
beat Galactus actually didn't realize it
no I haven't seen age of Ultron yet
somebody posted a really funny comment
about saying that like Squirrel Girl
he'd be Galactus and I was like what no
way and and I looked it up and so I was
like okay so so Jared Leto's Jared
Leto's Joker like a lot of people have
been asking me what do I think about
Jared Leto's Joker I think he looks
awesome like that that looks like a good
movie version of the Joker a cross
between like a serial killer who's like
an ex-felon or something like that I
should have a really an ex-felon but who
is a felon and it's like I mean he looks
like you would expect the Joker to look
in a movie if the movie we're gonna be
grounded in real life the question is
can Jared Leto pull off the Joker I mean
it's one thing to look like him it's
another to be able to pull the character
off accurately I don't know and we don't
really know what kind of Joker we're
gonna see in Suicide Squad you know are
we gonna see C Steve Englehart Joker
from like Batman the Animated Series or
are we gonna see more of like The Dark
Knight kind of Joker
I don't really know so I'm kind of
interested to see how he portrays that
character what's going on everybody
good morning oh wow people are like it's
wow it's 9:30 at night geez
but good no it's it's kind of a
it's kind of what's going on Taylor
people are slowly trickle in people who
are showing up here which is cool they
should cast Miley Cyrus no way I love
doing these Q&A sessions with you guys I
love talking to you guys and answering
questions that you guys have it's always
really fun you Joss Whedon or Zack
Snyder mm-hmm it's actually a tough one
um Zack Snyder makes characters or does
movies where the characters are more
grounded I think but there's just a
little bit of like flamboyance where
this character's a little too much posh
you know too much pizazz with his up
with this things he he feels like the
michael bay of DC films like there was a
bunch of unnecessary destruction and Man
of Steel Man of Steel could have easily
just focused on Superman and it didn't
really have to be this movie that just
broke down into like all this
destruction and all these things blowing
up it looks kind of silly Joss Whedon is
similar and John Sweden does great
movies and his run on x-men was was it
was stellar
but Avengers is just like oh my god we
have all these characters like let's
just blow stuff up let's just like
destroy things and that's cool but you
know I mean as long as movies
entertaining people are gonna enjoy it
and I was like you're thinking about
this on the way back from from getting
breakfast this morning
I had these two bases myself
periodically and I'm hoping not the only
one who does that but it was funny
listening to or thinking about all this
because I think that the excitement for
Avengers was there because people
finally got to see all the characters
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
team-up into one movie that's what
people were excited for it the action
was just a byproduct you know I think
that too much action can be overwhelming
in the end the movie just needs to be
you know interesting it just needs to be
entertaining but a movie can be slow
focusing on the character and still be
entertaining you know just as much as it
can be over-the-top action and still be
entertaining it's just difficult to find
a balance between the two but you know
um they they have their pluses and
minuses you know Joss Whedon and and
Zack Snyder both have their ups and
downs
so let's see hey Rob do you think
spider-man will meet kingpin in the MCU
I hope so
you know I would love to see like a
spider-man cameo and the daredevil
Netflix series not even like a big one
it could just be like one episode and
Daredevils like I need your help to take
down the kingpin and spider-man's like
okay and that's it because we all know
that a kingpin was originally a
spider-man villain and so will be a
great homage to the history of kingpin
in the comics to see that happen but
again you know while these are based on
characters in the comics and they're
based on how the characters are depicted
in the comics it's not a direct
reflection of the comics and so we may
not necessarily see that which isn't a
bad thing you know it's just interesting
am I going to attempt the Marvel film
marathon probably not I mean the
daredevil thing was fun but at the end
of the day it was me just sitting in
front of a camera for 13 hours I
probably won't do that again I want to
start Marvel Comics on YouTube any tips
man send me a message on send me an
email
Robin Marvel explained calm thoughts on
Civil War who God well I spent three
months doing it so it must be good
Civil War is a fantastic story and it's
funny that you asked that question
because I'm going to be working on on
Ragnarok later on today and when I do
we're gonna focus on the event and then
we're also going to talk about the
character and so I think that's really
gonna be a cool discussion because I
think there's a lot of confusion for
like non comic-book readers a lot of
people said oh my god they're gonna do
Thor Ragnarok and everybody seems really
excited about it why and they did a
search and I like ring the rocks person
II I don't understand this and there's
something about an event but they don't
really know how to decipher the
difference between the two of them and
so that's what we gonna do in the video
we're gonna talk about Raina rock or
well actually have to go over the
history of Asgard to be honest because
the only way to really understand how
Ragnarok happens and why it happens is
to understand the history of Asgard and
how asgaard comes into existence those
of you guys guys who know about Ragnarok
the event know exactly what I'm talking
about but it's really the only way to
make to make that make sense
which infinity stone would I rather hold
Oh God
probably the reality stone because I
could do everything else if I have the
reality stone what do I think of
conversion so far convergence is all
right not the biggest fan but a lot of
the stories are stories I never read and
so those characters don't really like
hit home for me you know it's not like
it would be with secret wars where they
do you know future imperfect and I'm
like oh my god yes future imperfect like
the mics Jarrow Incredible Hulk vs the
credit incredible hope from the present
timeline they meet and they fight I mean
that'd be kind of a cool for me that
that's that's a really cool concept you
know but you know X benign T to like
really hits home for me you know The
Adventures of Superman from 1980
something just doesn't really hit home
for me it doesn't really matter to me
that much you know it doesn't it doesn't
resonate with me like oh my god this is
amazing you know and in truth you know
I'm gaining a new respect for DC as I'm
you know delving into DC content here on
my channel now but DC doesn't really
like impact me the same way that Marvel
does you know Marvel is always gonna
hold you know a step ahead of DC and in
my book I think you know just because
it's I spent so long reading it and it's
just it was part of my youth as part of
my upbringing there's so much nostalgia
tied into it would like and that doesn't
mean either either one's better than the
other which I saw your all's debate
about Marvel vs. DC you guys kill me
with that stuff
it is neither one's better than the
other they both have pluses they both
have minuses they need each other to be
honest like Marvel needs DC and DC needs
Marvel like DC Spurs Marvel on for
competition
you know DC says ok we're gonna be
rebooting our entire continuity I'm
almost says well we got to do something
you know and DC says well we're gonna
give Superman a new power so Marvel says
oh we got to do something you know and
Marvel says hey let's start like a film
Cinematic Universe and DC says well we
got to do something you know I mean
that's that's the great thing about
comment about about you know the
competition is that one Spurs the other
because each one's trying to beat the
other out and so you know it's it's
really a cool concept I think at the end
of the day when you when
look at it what are your thoughts about
the Superman versus Batman teaser
trailer well okay here's the thing I
wanted to do a reaction video for
Superman vs Batman but one of others
copyrighted the video and so if I were
to upload it even with my reaction it'd
be copyrighted material and that would
cause problems for my channel hmmm it
didn't look that great to be honest it
looked like you know and let's let's
talk about this let's let's spend a few
minutes you know talking about about
this trailer you know a good morning
master Jay man it looked like it was
really just slammed in there it looked
like they had taken you know two pieces
of a puzzle that didn't match and just
like crammed them together that's not a
trailer Feld you know um it doesn't mean
the movies gonna be bad it just means I
think that whoever it was that made this
trail did a piss-poor job it could be
that the movies gonna be bad I'll go see
it you know there's no way I'm next I'm
not gonna go so there's no way that I'm
not gonna see that I definitely would
have to but you know it looks it looks
like DC it looks like you know wonder
brother said okay look like Nolan's Dark
Knight series was really really really
popular people loved it it's one of the
best Batman series of all time I think
we can all unanimously agree that you
know agree to that and they said okay
Man of Steel was and it was relatively
successful made a bunch of money you
know if it was a Superman movie why
wouldn't it make a whole bunch of money
and so they said how can we get these
two together and so they said let's just
make a movie and and that was it
you know I don't I don't really think
there was a whole lot of thought put
into it I don't really think there was a
grandiose plan and that I think is the
inherent difference between the DC films
and the Marvel films I think that with
Iron Man Marvel took a gamble Marvel
said let's just make an Iron Man film
and see what happens you know with the
Incredible Hulk
I think it was similar but I think that
once Iron Man took off you know took off
Marvel Studios said we can really do
something with this and we can really
turn this into something cool and so
they developed a plan now I think they
also accounted for the fact that the
plan my plan might you know flop
entirely that when Marvel sat down and
they said okay Iron Man one has a
Pikul success I mean fans were just like
this is what we've been waiting for in a
superhero movie you know a down to earth
like a real-world version of a superhero
but who's also like a superhero you know
and Marvel not shying away and saying
well I mean yeah he's kind of a
superhero but you know not really you
know they were like yes this man has a
metal suit and he flies around and
shoots rays out of his hands like done
and done you know fans were like this is
what we wanted an Iron Man that's what
we wanted in a cinematic film and you
know when they said okay let's let's
launch this movie Iron Man just blew up
and they said okay let's let's just do a
big picture like what do we want the end
goal of all this to be and maybe was
Joss Whedon maybe it was somebody else
but they sat down and they said Infinity
Gauntlet one of the most successful
stories in the history of DC's entire
continuity everybody knows about the
Infinity Gauntlet people who don't read
comics know about the Infinity Gauntlet
and so they said okay how do we get
there
what's going on so TECA good morning but
they said how do we get there and so
they develop this plan in between and
that I think is the success of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they had a
plan they they set things in motion to
where it all came together and it all
made sense I think that Warner Brothers
is basically taking concepts from DC
movies and they're just like it's
throwing them at the wall and they're
saying okay what's popular and what's
not and they're kind of swinging for the
fences
trying to keep pace with what Marvel's
doing Fox I think is the same way with
the other you know model related
properties with x-men with Fantastic
Four you know that kind of thing but I
think it's quite clear than when it
comes to cinematic movies one was
leading the way now that is live-action
animation or I'm sorry live-action
movies when it comes to animated movies
DC takes the cake hands down like do you
see has some of the best animated movies
you ever gonna see in your life I mean
they're mind-blowing I've never seen a
DC animated film that I didn't like so
that I think is a testament to where DC
can can really find their bread and
butter nothing if DC sticks to what
works you know and they they evolve from
there because things change everything
changes you can't just stick with what
works all the time otherwise the wheel
never gets invented but if they had a if
they could if they went with animation
and then just kind of let their universe
expand from there
then it would it would become something
awesome but you know I don't I don't
know if DC doesn't see it that way or
what but regardless so so let's answer
some more questions let's see let's
scroll back up no I don't have any ribs
let's see there was one question I
thought okay okay that is a question so
you're saying that in DC there are
thousands of people with Infinity stones
the lantern race yes but no there's a
big difference between the Atlanta
between the Lantern rings and the
Infinity stones the Infinity stones
control one facet of something like you
have the reality gem which can which
allows a person to manipulate the fabric
of reality they can if a person had the
reality stone they could open a black
hole right next to you suck you in and
then close it up and that would be it
that's something somebody could do with
the reality Jim with the reality Jim
they could turn the planet earth into a
marble I mean they could just do
whatever they wanted to in reality that
doesn't mean they could endow themselves
with any power it just means they could
do whatever they wanted to with reality
now the other gyms follow the same
pattern the time Jim the Space Jam the
mind gym so on and so forth the the
Rings just kind of let you do whatever
you could imagine you know within reason
I think that that Green Lantern's used
to be able to time travel with and that
was retconned or something like that I
came off top my head but hello from
Romania feet what's going on my Romanian
friend
let's see Rob do you think a cigar could
come down onto earth and the movies and
infinity war one or two okay are you
thinking about like post-civil war
because if because if you're talking
about civil war like after Ragnarok or
after Ragnarok you know when a scart was
destroyed when Thor died all that stuff
you're talking about with like went for
we created a scarred and then place it
like above Oklahoma because that'd be a
great way to tie things in and do too
basically do that but I don't know um
they could but I'm not sure how I'd feel
about that hey Rob are you planning on
doing a video on the runaways or the
Young Avengers ah not really because it
was really not a reason to I mean I mean
at some point you know but I mean that
it doesn't really seem like there's a
reason to do it at this point and did
not like throne of Atlantis yeah it was
a bad throne of Atlantis wasn't wasn't
terrible I got a half way through the
story and in the actual comics and just
I really didn't find it too interesting
but the the movie was decent enough and
the movie had me entertained long enough
that I watched it all but it wasn't
memorable like I don't really remember a
whole lot from it I remember that this
seemed like there was a battle that
Atlantis invaded the the service and
Aquaman took his rightful place as king
of the Atlanteans or I guess of the of
Atlantis I'm not sure if that's exactly
what happened but I don't remember off
top my hand
how did Falcon become Captain America
okay so let's explain it that's a really
good question
how did Falcon become Captain America
Falcon became Captain America for a
couple reasons there was a segment
leading up to time runs out I think but
here is okay here's one of the things
that that you guys have to understand we
may I may just kind of explain it here
and leave it here but when Marvel had
the incursions of him and they were
introducing like all these things with
time runs out time runs out starts eight
months later and so all the solos
stories of the characters take place
during that eight month period
Falcon becoming Captain America Steve
Rogers becoming old takes place during
that eight month period for losing his
ability to wield the hammer and then the
female version of Thor appearing takes
place during that eight month period
that's what all that happens and so
that's why you know it's it's eight
months later because it gave Marvel the
ability to say okay all these stories
that you see going on right now leading
up to the end of every
thing in the Marvel Universe takes place
during that a month period that's why we
still have Captain America's solo
stories a solo series that's what we
still have for issue number seven issue
and number eight which comes out in May
that actually reveals the identity of
the new female Thor that's the entire
basis behind that and so time runs out
as Marvel's lead-up event to sicker
worse 2015 but anyway that that's the
entire reason why I'm sorry that's
that's the basis for eight months out
baby yeah
for eight months later um how it was
that okay
for Daisy how it was that Captain
America
I guess Falcon became Captain America
was due to the fact that Steve Rogers
actually traveled to the oh god
dimension Z the dimension of Arnim Zola
and he'd spent some time there they were
trying to find a way to extract the
Super Soldier Serum from his body
whatever he eventually came back to the
normal earth-616 universe with like a
surrogate son so to speak who was the
son of Arnim Zola it's really kind of
confusing but the fact remains that
eventually a guy named bubble bubble man
I think it was I came here as a mouth
top my head it was a he was a dumb
villain that was introduced just for the
sake of making this happen but uh
Captain America lost the Super Soldier
Serum it was literally drained from his
body and as a result he passed the
mantle on to Captain Falcon this all
took place in Captain America vol 7
issue numbered like like 23 or 24 I
think he was already but let's yeah for
Daisy don't spam dude otherwise I'm just
gonna delete your email but the
Submariner is a fantastic for Ally
villains so it can Fox use him in a
Fantastic Four movie yes the Submariner
is owned by both Marvel and Fox and so
or no I'm sorry he's owned by Marvel in
Universal I think he's owned by
Universal and so they can use both can
use them if they choose to you but I
doubt they will let's see
do I think Deadpool could make an
appearance at the Marvel Cinematic
Universe probably not I mean I don't see
why Fox would even remotely allow that
to happen there they're gonna make a ton
of money off the film there I doubt they
would do that because the model would
want a portion of the proceeds Marvel
would say hey look guys like if you guys
want to see or if you guys want you know
Deadpool to appear in Marvel Cinematic
Universe or if we have them up here like
we want like 20% of like how much of the
money that he makes of the of the money
that comes from the film that he appears
in and that there's no way Fox is gonna
do that so no I'm not gonna blacklist
hagas you guys talk about haggis all you
want to I don't care Rob do you think
the MCU will bring The Avengers where
the founding members are not on the team
they might at some point you know okay
that the Batman is getting banned block
user done it done okay we have no time
for any of that nonsense Milner is in
full effect I'm sure they would I mean
why wouldn't they now you can't have
Tony Stark playing you know
Iron Man forever you know you can't have
Chris Evans playing Captain America
forever you know not to mention an age
of Ultron we have the vision now we have
Scarlet Witch no I kind of saw you know
let's see
Rob I just wanted to thank you for
getting me hooked on Hickman's run of
Avengers and new avengers at the
Hyperion video I been shredded and it's
amazing and epic in scale oh yes it is
man it's been going on for like three
years it's freaking awesome like I
really really love it all right let's
see what's up with the weekly pool is it
no longer weekly um no we just took a
break last week is all it was like we
were really really really busy and we
were really exhausted and we just felt
like taking a break so we're so I now
still on Twitter again if you guys don't
you guys don't follow me on Twitter
that's where all the stuff gets updated
like where I throw out all my
information or not my information but
like you know where I thought updates
for the weekly pool stuff like that also
make sure you guys follow the weekly
pool on Twitter
because that's where a lot of
announcements get made and things like
that with regards to to the podcast and
and so on so do I think the Punisher
will be in the MCU most certainly I mean
why wouldn't you have Frank Castle in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and here's
a really cool thing and the stage has
been set to have Frank Castle I mean if
daredevil did anything it gave
legitimacy to like street-level
superheroes and so it'd be very easy for
Marvel to come along and say hey guys
like you know how like all these things
have been happening well like this
entire time there's been some crazy
[ __ ] running around the streets of
Hell's Kitchen New York with like a
12-gauge shotgun and a skull on his
chest killing people it'd be really easy
for them to do so you know I could I can
easily see them doing that let's see who
should Marvel get the film rights for oh
who should you who should they get the
film rights back for the x-men the
Fantastic Four I don't really care about
you know the Fantastic Four haven't been
relevant since like Hickman's run I mean
that was the last time they mattered so
yeah I'd say the exponent robably the
ones I should get back so does the
Marvel is a giant brother who floats
through some kind of space from the lead
up to the old amalgam universe crossover
still so many questions coming in across
over still apply is that Marvel
multiverse ad at highest level that okay
I'm gonna have to come back and read
that later cuz my mind is very sluggish
at the moment
this coffee will help to speed up my
thought process Rob you ever do a video
on the century already have I do I think
spider-man would wear the iron spider
and the Civil War maybe okay we were
actually talking about that um we talked
about that during the podcast with eros
with variant comics yes like we're so
hoping so here was here was actually I
think as soon as that this was heiresses
idea
the his idea was if you look at the
trailer for ant-man
the villain yellow jacket looks
extraordinarily close to the iron spider
from Civil War and so people were light
people were like what if Marvel just
like repainted that outfit and made it
the iron spider and I was like that is a
genius idea so I really hope we see that
I don't know if we will but I really
hope we see that let's see the short
from the film where they had all of them
trying to pick up Thor's hammer and
Captain move in I mean that could be I
don't know if that'll be for losing his
hammer
I doubt though ever loses hammer in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe did I do a
what war a whole video yet no no I
haven't if the core members of the
Justice League and the Avengers fight
who will who will win oh wow if the core
members of the Avengers fight the core
members of the Justice League who would
win honestly and a lot of you guys are
gonna hate me for this I had to give it
to the Justice League they would
probably beat the core member of the
Avengers but okay but we have to okay we
have to identify rosters so the core
members of the Justice League
it is pretty much been the same lineup
forever so we've got Aquaman Martian
Manhunter Green Lantern the flash
Superman Wonder Woman and I guess cyborg
whatever okay the core members of the
Justice League all right I mean the core
embers of the Justice League
we've got Thor we've got the Incredible
Hulk Iron Man Captain America Scarlet
Witch okay okay okay House of M Avengers
that was when the Avengers I think right
there at their peak the most powerful
version of The Avengers now all the
Justice League takes in the Justice
League what would would beat the
Avengers I mean that's I really
can't see I can't see any other way of
that going down I mean no because I mean
the Justice League has Superman they've
got the Green Lantern two of the most
powerful characters right there you've
got Martian Manhunter which is more
powerful than both of them you got
Batman you know you got you got oh my
god you got all these cared no there's
there's no way the Avengers win not by a
long shot
now if we're talking about the core
Justice League lineup versus the x-men
Justice League would get obliterated
destroyed so fast to be unbelievable
like it would be pitiful
but only everybody's like you miss
Batman you miss Batman
no I didn't miss Batman and Batman
missed me
which moral property do I want to see
adapted into the big screen um okay like
property is in team or like story I'm
gonna take it as an as in team that I
want to see a doctor's the big screen I
mean honestly the big names have really
just kind of been dropped already I mean
you've got the x-men you got the
Fantastic Four you got spider-man you
got the Avengers there's other smaller
ones I mean you've got like like the
Captain Britain Corps but the Captain
Britain Corps is rarely ever relevant
you've got I mean I mean all the big
ones are been dropped out that okay so
of the small ones I'll rather I'd like
to see this century if I had to pick any
one to be adapted to the big screen it
would be Robert Reynolds it would be
this century
either that or Adam Brashear blue Marvel
because that dude is a powerhouse it is
nuts how strong that guy is that guy is
a strong if not stronger than this
century and the century fought the
Incredible Hulk to a standstill so take
that for what it's worth like that dude
is it's like stupid how powerful that
guy is oh my god no scope 420 blaze it
oh man phase four the wind Rob versus DC
who wins this needs to be answered oh I
win like hands down I win
you know how I would win like I would
just erase them from existence
what character should appear in MCU in
phase 3 and phase 4 okay I was thinking
about this like yesterday I was thinking
about where does muffle go beyond face
for around Beyond phase 3 because phase
3 is like infinity war so it's just like
okay like in infancy here's a really
cool thing about infinity war those of
you guys who read Infinity Gauntlet know
that like everybody dies I mean Thanos
snaps his fingers half the life in the
universe vanishes and then the rest get
obliterated by Thanos when he has the
infamy when I say obliterated I mean
like no contests I mean like like it's
not even fair and even like during the
conflict Adam warlock was talking to the
Silver Surfer and Silver Surfer was like
do you think they can win and Adam
warlock was like of course not like
they're not supposed to win like this is
they're just a distraction like we're
waiting for something much bigger to
happen you know I think that um I think
that that yeah I think that with
Infinity Gauntlet
it gives Marvel a chance to reset their
continuity like it gives them a chance
to go back and to reboot everything it
would give them the chance to go back
and say okay here's like a new team of
Avengers I mean not necessarily reboot
and saying okay here's like the new
Ironman or anything but in the sense
that he would allow them to kill off
characters or contracts are ending and
bring in new characters so you know
after infinity war we could see Bucky
Barnes take on the role of Captain
America you know or Falcon even you know
after infinity war we could see the
introduction of new characters we know
that with phase 3 the Inhumans are gonna
be coming in with their first films so
obviously the Inhumans are gonna be part
of phase 4 going forward they're gonna
be probably a mainstay in phase 4
they're gonna be a big part of that
phase I mean we've got a multitude of
other things we've got cosmic entities
we have I mean you've got all different
other Avengers that we've never even
mentioned before I mean you've got a
huge Alya we got the Captain Britain
Corps you got the Sentry got I mean you
got so much that Marvel could do face 4
it's mind-boggling to think of where it
could go
in my personal opinion like my dream I
think that Captain America 3 Civil War
should set the stage where it's like the
beginnings of this fallout and then I
think all of phase 4 should be
war that would be my my thing because
well the time phase for comes around
that means that now they could fold in
agents of shield into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe into the actual movie
themselves it means he in humans are
part of the movies now it means that
daredevil that Punisher Jessica Jones
Luke Cage Danny ran the iron fist like
all of these things are part of the
Cinematic Universe now and that I think
would be would be pre stellar in terms
of being able to launch a full-scale
like phase of civil war movies that
would be freakin amazing
okay let's see since you're getting into
DC now what storyline has really won me
over
um what stories really won me over I'd
say pretty much all the Batman story so
far
core to the Alice tonight at the owls in
game those have been really really solid
I've and this is actually kind of a
funny thing
I really haven't enjoyed most anything
else from new 52 to be honest there's
really like nothing from new 52 that
intrigues me that interests me i sat
down and try to read some of the
Superman stuff and it's just not so
that's why I think Batman has been such
a mainstay for DC comic fans in so long
because you know Batman is a guy who's
really rich and he has gadgets it's so
easy to make great stories with Batman
all you have to do is pit him against
overwhelming odds against like an
overwhelming force or just throwing the
Joker and the Batman is gonna have a
great story I mean Superman can't have
that great of a story because he's
Superman I mean unless you're talking
about Darkseid or you know some cosmic
level being that wants to like kill
Superman you really can't you know beat
anybody like here I mean you really
can't beat him like that that's it you
know and so it's really difficult for me
to to identify with Superman to say I
love this story about Superman because
all the story would come down to his
Superman just pummeling a guy just like
absolutely beating him up Batman it is
to a degree but Batman you get like all
you know development and all this
discussion and all this you know
detective work and plotting and stuff
and it's really cool to read how all
that comes about and how it all kind of
fits into this final story so really
Batman's the only one that I identify
with that I really enjoy for from DC
like in its entirety let's see hey Rob
which which new phase three character
are you looking forward to the most the
Inhumans definitely like I'm really
excited to see what they do with the
Inhumans now here's what I think is
gonna happen if those of you guys who
have been following agents of shield we
know that like Skye isn't a human now
and that Skye's with their mother I
think here's what I think's happening
here's what I think has happened
you have the inhuman royal family all
right which will obviously see in the
Inhumans movie you'll see Black Bolt
Medusa
you know Gorgon or Gordon rather and the
rest of all the other guys you know
you'll see all of them there I think
that what they did is they said okay
like we're gonna create these like
little villages or a little town so to
speak what we're gonna have people that
like teach other Inhumans how to
function how to become Inhumans and then
when the time comes if they choose to
they can join in human society that way
they won't show up on the doorstep of
the inhuman royal family of Attilan and
then just start blowing stuff up because
they have no idea how to use their
powers I think that that sky will be our
introduction into the Inhumans I think
and fingers crossed no idea if we'll
actually see this or not I think we'll
see some measure of introduction for the
inhuman royal family in agents of shield
I think we might get a mention of Black
Bolt we might get a mention of you know
like Medusa or something like that we
might even see Medusa because she's it's
you know I don't think they're gonna
cast like a major actress like a high
salary actress to play her so it's not
gonna cost you no agency is not gonna
cost immortal like five million dollars
to have this actress show up as Medusa
you know I think that'd be a great way
to segue in but again you know I don't
know Rob you're awesome keep it up homie
I appreciate it
Captain America versus black panther
mm probably black panther like panthers
1/3 smartest person on the planet so I'm
pretty sure he could out think Steve
Rogers oh let's see
why don't I prefer Marvel DC because I
was raised on Marvel I mean I've been
reading modeling my whole life so it
just resonates with me more so you are
my YouTube superhero in my book I
appreciate a sunlight I really
appreciate it okay so here's my question
for you guys let's think of a good
question because I like asking you guys
questions too
okay here's a really good question if
you guys could assign members if you
guys could assign one person from DC
Comics hmm if you could assign one
person from DC Comics the reality gem
who would it be
who would you give the reality gem to
that's my question to you guys like I
want to know who you would give it to
let's see
Batman is everyman that's why he appeals
to so many people and that's exactly it
you know like anybody could be Batman I
guess if they have their parents killed
when they're when they're kids and and
that's it you know and then yeah
and they become billionaires then sure
anybody's Batman but I get what you're
saying I get what you're saying
should the MCU bring in new characters
to take over the roles of roles like the
James Bond franchise mm-hmm I know what
you mean like when we watch for Sean
Connery and so on I don't know oh my god
the comments are flowing in oh I don't
know how I feel about that I mean Robert
Downey jr. like made Tony suck he
brought Tony Stark to life I couldn't
see anybody else playing Tony Stark
besides him I don't know I mean the
Chris Evans playing playing Captain
America I mean you know Anthony Mackie
playing Falcon he's a great Falcon you
know
um I'm not really sure you know I don't
know I mean I'm not sure how I feel
about that but sure I'd be okay with
that uh let's see
oh my god okay so let's Larfleeze that's
the money we get with Larfleeze
like all our fleas wants to do is eat
because of his ring
so let's grow up and see some of these
responses Batman because he wouldn't use
it no way like half the fun is using it
like you gotta use the gym Lex Luthor
quake is not an inhuman in the comics
actually have a video about Daisy
Johnson too if you want to check that
out
Darkseid Darkseid with the reality Jim
are you serious like you would destroy
everything let's see the flash clarion
jason todd you'd give it to the Joker
Jonathan Hall would bring ruin to us all
by bringing it and giving it to the
Joker the guy gardener dr. fate to the
reality didn't the Joker at Green
Lantern Shazam The Joker Wonder Woman
the Joker hands down the specter God
Matt Lobo and you guys want to like
destroy reality I think like if you guys
are terrible people if you could give
any DC or marvel character a TV show who
would I give it to Oh God any DC or give
the reality Jim the bad cow if I could
give any reality any DC or a Marvel
character at reality TV show who would
it be la wouldn't give it to the New
Warriors because they cost civil war
when they did that so no that's a
terrible idea
hmm and have to be somebody interesting
like somebody whose life would be
interesting I don't know
do you see your mobile let me think
about it this way a day in the life of
blank you know who would you who would
who would that person be okay oh okay
I'll answer this question but I'm gonna
ask you guys the same question too like
who would you guys make a reality TV
show out of if you had the the if you
could give a reality TV show to one
character from the Justice or from DC or
marvel who would you give it to um I
probably give it to the Punisher like I
would want to see a day in the life of
the Punisher like that would be awesome
reality is no fun and so you screw it
happen that's true well I ever do moon
not explained I'm wanting to get into
the character but have no clue what's
good to read from her just read the read
well I think it's cancelled now but the
the Marvel now run of a moon night is a
great place to start I think it might
actually still be going on I'm not a
hundred percent sure I didn't read it I
didn't follow it I'm not a big fan of
Moon Knight but but as I understand it
like that's a great you know that's a
great place to start
spider Jerusalem it's spider-man
Constantine Deadpool Galactus are you
serious now you're okay you're just
throwing you're just throwing names out
there a day in the life of Galactus
Booster Gold the Emma Frost show see
okay see I knew this is gonna be coming
the whole reason why you guys want to
see like like a reality show about Emma
Frost or Power Girl is because you're
hoping you're hoping you'd be able to
see their boobs like that's why you guys
are doing it the punisher as well but it
would have to be rated it has to be on
after 10:00 p.m. and ready to TV mature
it has to be a reality show unlike like
HBO which I would love heroes for oh god
Heroes for Hire would make a really good
show okay so somebody what do you guys
asked me once if I could give a Netflix
series to anybody who would it be I
would pick Heroes for Hire Heroes for
Hire would be such a great Netflix TV
show which now that I think about it
I mean imagine if you just had like Iron
Fist
and Luke Cage they just teamed up and
they were like okay we're gonna start
Heroes for Hire wouldn't it be a great
place to go like after the defenders
when the defenders are done and then
like mom was like what do we do next
and they say Heroes for Hire and then we
have Danny Rand and we have Luke Cage
starting Heroes for Hire how awesome
would that be cuz I mean it'd be a great
Netflix TV series it'd be a combination
of humor it'd be funny it'd be you know
dark it'd be action-packed to be a great
show like it'd be just a fun show to
watch you know and I would really really
dig that
do I like ward from agents of shield oh
yeah horrid is a great character from
agents of shield I loved his character
you know he's a great I'd love to meet
that guy he's a great actor like I love
the character that he plays isn't Heroes
for Hire more or less the defenders and
not necessarily the Heroes for Hire are
literally heroes that you can hire for a
job like if if if a woman was like
mugged and the cops were just like we
don't care then she could hire the
Heroes for Hire
and they would go find the person that
mugged her they'd beat the ever-loving
Christ out of him and then they would
give that woman her stuff back and
that's it like that's basically it a day
in the life of Wonder Woman rated 18
plus well I do the Riddler explained oh
maybe I'm not sure The Adventures of
Alfred would be great I don't know
world war machine took over the role of
Iron Man in the MCU I mean he did in the
comics so I don't see why that wouldn't
happen in the MCU it may that may be
like face for stuff though you know I
could easily see that happening a day in
the life of Legion okay you want to do a
video you want to do a reality show
about a character that has hundreds of
personalities all of which have their
own powers like you'd like the guy would
just be sitting in a chair muttering to
himself and he would just like burst
into flames and he'd travel through time
and he'd jump back and then he'd start
reading minds and then he'd start moving
stuff around it'd be weird like it'd be
crazy but it would be entertaining so I
will give him that
Thomas Wayne Batman the life of James
Rhodes war machine when will Adam
warlock be introduced well we're not
sure that he will be you know as far as
I understand it I think the marbles
intention when the cocoon I think is
because James Gunn came out and said yes
that's the cocoon of Adam warlock and
guardians of the galaxy he came out and
said that like October of last year I
think I think that that was more of like
an odd well they were like yes Adam
warlock exists in this universe but if
we do see him we'll probably see him in
guardians of the galaxy too although we
may not see him until face four or we
may not see him until infinity war I
mean you don't really need Adam warlock
for the Infinity Gauntlet event but he
was really important to the Infinity
Gauntlet event and so I really couldn't
see how you could do it without him but
you know that's that's really more of
like that's fanservice if they brought
and Adam warlock in that's part of
infinity war that would be fanservice it
would just be like hey you remember like
all you fans we're like when Adam
warlock like sacrificed all the
earthbound heroes you know so that like
the cosmic entities could like fail I
mean you know that would just be
fanservice is all that is okay so here's
a question I'll ask of you guys if you
guys could hire one person if you guys
can choose one person to play Adam
warlock who would that person be that's
a good question for you guys
well you guys are mulling over that
question let's answer some more
questions um if I could give any
character the marvelous Sam if I could
give any Marvel Care ^ Sam who would it
be and why hmm any Marvel character well
it's got to be a street-level character
for me so I would say spider-man because
I think spider-man could use that power
intelligently but not abuse it I mean I
think that daredevil wouldn't want it
Luke Cage doesn't meet in The Punisher
would abuse the Punisher would have used
the hell out of that power like he would
use that power to like kill people more
efficiently than he does right now let's
see Morgan Freeman Ben Foster would be a
pretty decent Adam warlock Brad Pitt
ah Matthew McConaughey I don't know how
I feel about that the guy who played
Johnny Storm in Fantastic Four that's
Chris Evans that's the guy who's playing
Captain America right now
Kitty Pryde for Shazam
yeah Kitty Pryde wouldn't be the worst I
mean you could give it to somebody like
quinton choir because he would have used
it you couldn't give it to like Kate
Kilgore cause he'd abused it like he
would he'd kill people so Amadeus Cho
could definitely use it Amadeus chose
one of the smartest people on the planet
David Hasselhoff as the Beyonder I don't
know about that do you think we might
see Amadeus Cho in the MCU oh I think
definitely but here's a question do we
really even need to see Amadeus Cho I
mean he's really smart he's a cool
character but I mean I don't think we
really need Amadeus Cho it'd be cool to
see him though why is the earth-616 the
main universe
it was just that's it that's just the
way it was um way back when in the 1980s
when Alan Moore was writing for Marvel
when he was helping Marvel explain
expand into Britain with Marvel UK they
introduced a story called the crooked
world with Mad Jim Jasper's and they
introduced the Captain Britain core but
Alan Moore had to figure out a way to
differentiate between the mainstream
earth universe and all the other
universes because he was introducing an
expanded universe he was introducing
alternate realities what's going on
Kevin Holly and so he had to he had to
use a numerical differentiation and so
he just arbitrarily chose six one six
now as I understand it that's the reason
why he did it he just chose it randomly
that was it so that's just the number
that was assigned to it and that's
that's it so so that's why it's called
her six one six it's just an arbitrary
number selection on May is on May's
autumn warlock but uh we may do Messiah
Complex at some point I'm not sure
you I think the Joker would be great
friends dead no I think Deadpool will
try to kill the Joker like I think he
try to kill him am i excited for Secret
Wars hell yeah I'm excited for Secret
Wars oh my god which by the way guys um
time runs out we'll probably start all
chris smoove new chris smoove is the man
dude I've been following chris smoove
since like he's since modern warfare 2
days like I've been subscribed to his
channel well I wasn't my other channel I
need to research that again but I've
been following him since like modern
warfare 2 since what was it on file a
complaint on chris smoove i think there
was a first fit no the first video I
ever saw the he uploaded it was actually
kind of funny I I watched one where he
got to the very top on a high-rise and
he was talking about how if people let
somebody get up there then they deserve
to get like new tubed and so and then
like I saw that video then I couldn't
find his channel again and then I
finally found it again and I immediately
subscribed on following Chris move for a
long time which kudos to him he's at
like two and a half million subscribers
now like his channels blown up it's it's
nuts but yeah he's a really cool guy um
I forgot what we were talking about
before
I tried maple mountain breakfast at your
suggestion and it was awesome it is good
I'm glad you enjoyed it it doesn't hit
as well as I thought it would and the in
the Atlantis coil but oh yeah sigil Wars
um a secret Wars Marvel rebooting their
continuity but yeah Secret Wars will
probably start on Wednesday so I'm sorry
um Tom runs out we'll probably start on
lines out on Wednesday so we're
hopefully finish it by Wednesday I'm not
really sure yet but buddy yeah like
we're probably started on Wednesday
because that's when the final issue of
Avengers and new avengers comes out so
and then Secret Wars comes out May 2nd
that way by the time sticker worst comes
out well it'll be like we'll have the
videos ordered in such a way that we'll
finish time runs out and the next day be
able to cover Secret Wars number 1 so
I'm hoping fingers crossed I'm hoping
that's the way things end up so yeah
we're definitely gonna do more MCU
videos I'm gonna take like a day out of
the week and cover MCU videos because
you guys seem to love the
like that's nuts I should make a gaming
channel so you can game with me I mean I
just stream on Twitch but you know I
mean I might I mean I have like a gaming
channel it's called youtube.com slash I
fat stock but I never really it was a
call duty channel for a while but that
was it so I don't know um if I had to
recast abomination who would it be
I wouldn't like no way there's no way I
would recast abomination like what's his
name
god I kept the actor's name now but he
was the guy that played emil blonsky he
was a great actor for for that character
I love that idea
his wolf ain't gonna be back here in
Secret Wars all I can almost guarantee
it
I mean we're gonna get like x-men 92
Wolverine which in truth is the only
Wolverine that people really care about
like that's like the fan favorite
version of Wolverine so there's not
gonna be many complaints about seeing
that version come out let's see the
twitch link is twitch.tv slash marvel
explained I think Tim Roth fairness
thank you thank you I kept thinking Eli
Roth for some reason but I was like
there's no way that's right how do you
think the infinite I don't know what
you're gonna ask there of it what will
come with DC explain I mean I rolled all
that stuff over into Marvel explain so I
don't know we're in a comic explain now
so I don't maybe only gotten do a gaming
channel I'm not sure but will the
Punisher be in Civil War I hope so I
think you will I'm pretty sure you will
should I start reading convergence um
I mean yeah I'd say check out
convergence I mean just pick the titles
that really seemed to interest you
because that's really all it is I mean
convergences is just titles that
interest you I mean it that's really all
it's for I mean they're kind of written
away to where you kind of have to read
them but you don't it's really your it's
really your call but you know if you
were a fan of Silver Age Superman you
know right up until flashpoint ended
then check it out like definitely take a
look at it and see what you think about
Superman number one from convergence you
know if you were a fan of Wally West as
the flash and check out the flash number
1s convergence you know really it's
kinda Pinzon on what you want to do and
what interests you Rob who is your top 5
Marvel heroes without superpowers
without superpowers ooh The Punisher
number 1 um man I mean without powers ok
The Punisher number 1 whoo do they have
to be okay we're just gonna say
characters without powers because it's
difficult to do heroes without powers um
okay characters without powers top 5 um
Kade Kilgore number 1 Frank Castle
number 2
probably Alexander Pierce is number 3
since he was one of the members of the
Hellfire Club and then I don't know
maybe stick is number four and then
number five god it's a tough one I don't
know what I'd do for number five we
still got 2018 to make a deal with Fox
yes we do we have plenty of time Rob is
blue Marvel Hyperion and century models
versions of Superman yeah basically
that's pretty much what they are um
Hyperion is like the original like there
is like Marcus Milton as you have here's
the character that we covered that's the
most recent version
our older versions that we don't really
need to go into will probably go into
them once we get into squadron supreme
with Secret Wars but for right now we
don't really need to go into those
characters but Hyperion goes way back to
like the 1960s like squadron sinister
squadron supreme that kind of stuff and
then the century is another version of
Superman and then of course the current
version of Hyperion and then of course
Adam Brashear and you know s blue model
I would say Adam Brashear is bloom I'm
sorry that the current version of
Hyperion is the closest character Marvel
has to Superman and you know followed by
Adam Brashear is a close second and then
century is a third so I mean Hawkeye is
not that boring I don't think well the
century be in Secret Wars I don't know I
mean right now the century is dead so
I'm not sure I have what's going on is
that couch from Korea awesome
what time is it in Korea boom Marvel
isn't Supes though he has such faster
different yeah but I mean you're talking
super strength the ability to fly I mean
he the only thing he can't do this
Superman can do is shoot out a shoot
lasers out of his eyes at least to my
knowledge Adam Brashear can't shoot
lasers out of his eyes
let's see Rob could you do a video on
give you a Marvel fear itself' explained
um maybe I mean like I said if yourself
isn't really important right now like
all that stuff's gone those events are
over and the the ramifications aren't
really being felt right now so stick was
a total dick yes he was
when do I think the time Jim will appear
are you talked about in the comics
because it's gone forever are you
talking about of the MCU and I think
we'll see the time Jim let's see we need
the soul Jim and the time the sole Jim
and the time Jim are the only to
infinity gems that we haven't seen yet
and we have no idea where they are the
time Jim we'll probably see in Doctor
Strange it makes sense for the time Jim
to exist dr. strange because dr. strange
would say I'm holding on all the time
Jim because no one should mess with time
like that would make perfect sense the
soul Jim will probably see with Adam
warlock if we see it
like I think I think we will let's see
do I think ant-man will become giant man
no okay
for those of you guys who were curious
the difference between Hank Pym and
Scott Lang is that Scott Lang can only
shrink down in size Scott Lang can't
actually grow in size
hank pan can grow and shrink and then
there's Goliath who can only grow that's
a differentiation between Hank Pym and
everybody else Hank Pym you can shrink
and grow nobody else can do both yeah
I'm going to see Avengers on Thursday
and then I'm going to see it on Friday
and then I'm going to see it again on
Saturday so I'm gonna see it three times
so I'm not at all complaining let's see
let's scroll up a little bit well I do a
comic creators artists explained
I'd love to at some point um I'd even
like to throw in interviews but it'd be
kind of hard to do so well ever do a
video on annihilation um
maybe so the problem with those older
stories or stories like annihilation
annihilation conquests with you know
Messiah Complex Messiah Wars you know
host summers and generation hope and all
that kind of stuff those videos are I
mean those those events are long gone
and they're not really tied into
anything that's going on right now and
even then mom was rebooting their
continuity so there wouldn't really be a
point in doing those videos this you
know right now but you know we'll see
what's up what do you think the
post-credits scene will be in guardians
of the galaxy - I think the post-credits
scene in guardians of the galaxy T will
be Thanos gaining the Infinity like
assembling the Infinity Gauntlet either
that are like meeting with mr. steth
like wouldn't would that be a cool I
post-credits scene if like at the end of
at the end of guardians of the galaxy -
like Thanos assembles the Infinity
Gauntlet then goes to mistress death and
it was and it's like you know what must
I do to prove my love to you and then it
just gets the black like that would be
freakin amazing
how powerful is Annihilus Annihilus has
a cosmic control rod so he can do almost
anything but he has the annihilation
wave which is literally a wave of bugs
that just eat everything that's quite
literally what it is let's see let's see
now that age of Ultron is already out
what Marvel movie are you looking
forward to the most Captain America 3 I
mean I'll go see ant-man nah man there's
no way I wouldn't see Ant Man but
Captain America 3 is definitely the most
the movie that I'm looking to looking
forward to the most
Rob who would you cast as a Galactus in
a Fantastic Four movie as the voice of
Galactus I'm probably James Earl Jones
as the voice of Galactus I may have to
be somebody with like a deep booming
voice so probably change Darryl Jones I
mean if it was like Morgan Freeman it
would sound like Galactus was just like
narrating his consumption of planets
which would be cool but no I wouldn't
worry let's see do I ever play the old
versus DC Marvel DC car actually never
played Marvel DC card games so hang with
the time Jim I mean they actually in the
current run what was it in a yeah and in
Captain America I'm sorry you know the
New Avengers or Avengers number 30
numbers 31 31
it was the original santi and what was
his name came the Conqueror actually all
the generations of Kang Kang the
Conqueror and mortis and I kind of Riku
the younger kid was they sealed away the
time Jim so let's see is there anyone
oops we missed that question is there
anyone that can stop the beyonders hold
on do I understand that correctly let's
scroll up
is there anyone that can stuff the
beyonders that model hasn't brought in
yet know the the know the beyonders
can't be stopped okay Oh for those of
you guys who are who are curious okay
let's say let's say this cup represents
the Marvel multiverse all right this is
this Cup inside this Cup
is the ultimate universe the earth-616
universe the House of M universe Age of
Apocalypse all that stuff is all
concealed inside this Cup everything
outside of this cup is the beyond versa
so the B owners are extraordinarily
powerful there's there's no one as
unless the only exception to that is
that if everything exists inside this
Cup including the beyond verse and
including the beyonders in which case
the one above all is would easily be
able to stop the beyonders unless of one
above all steps in and Marvel makes that
concrete and says okay the beyonders are
are not more powerful than the one above
all then there's no one that can stop
the beyonders so but it's not they're
gonna stop anyway I mean Tom Brevoort
told us that no one's gonna be able to
stop what's happening it's impossible so
it's not a cop it's a big red guy from a
Malcolm crossover I couldn't get into
ultimate yeah ultimate s'alright
you know Ultimates decent-enough Oh Star
Wars yeah Star Wars I'm looking forward
to Star Wars comes out in December this
is gonna be a big year and we've got a
vengers to age of Ultron that just came
out we've got Ant Man that comes out
Jessica Jones is coming out later on
this year on Netflix and we've got Star
Wars coming out to the end of the year
so anyway guys we've been doing this for
many hours so so again we usually cut
these things at about an hour so I'm
gonna go ahead and bounce off here I'm
gonna get to work on I'm working on this
rhino rock vid so again we're gonna
cover like the origins of Asgard in this
video so those of you guys would want to
know how has guard came into existence
we're gonna talk about that which is
it's really kind of a cool origin story
it's all very similar to how you would
expect it to be told you know if you
were talking to somebody from Norway or
somebody who speaks in Icelandic from
the Icelandic culture
but anyway I'm gonna bounce off here
guys I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of Commerce in coffee thank you
for coming out like it's so fun to talk
to you guys you know you guys are always
always an awesome crowd and and yeah so
I will catch you guys later peace